good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2023 2024
foundations's biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science s our series is focused on
the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to differing themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences our theme this year
is on building Partnerships for
generative AI training in biomedical and
clinical research where we enjoy on
Fridays uh lectures from a wide range of
leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging efforts in
AI based methods applied to biomedical
science importantly we hear about the
efforts of Faculty Educators in training
the next generation of biomedical
researchers to properly utilize these
tools indeed we wish to remind folks
that our 2023 2024 application cycle is
now open and we encourage Junior faculty
members working in areas such as
development of generative AI methods
applied to biomedical research and those
Junior faculty utilizing Ai and their
biomedical teaching to consider applying
we believe this is a very exciting and
engaging program bringing together AI
platform developers with University
level Educators to better understand the
power the promise the potential perils
associated with generative AI
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage seminars such as these as vital
material in our culminating in-person
manuscript and Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the bajia
beachfront Resort in San Diego
California in June of 2024 today I am
absolutely delighted to welcome our
speaker Professor Don Brown from the
University of
Virginia Professor Brown is the senior
associate Dean for research and the
quantitative Foundation distinguished
professor in data science and the Ws
calcott professor in the department of
systems and information engineering at
the University of Virginia he earned his
bachelor's degree from the United States
Military Academy and holds two master's
degrees um it from the University of
California Berkeley and his PhD from the
University of Michigan
prior to joining the University of
Virginia Dr Brown served as an officer
in the US Army and later worked at
Vector Research Incorporated on projects
in medical information processing and
multisensor surveillance systems he is a
fellow of the i e and a past president
of the I E Systems man and cybernet
Society he was a past recipient of the
Norbert weiner award for outstanding
research in areas of systems engineering
data fusion and information analysis and
he is the was the founding director of
the data Science Institute here at UVA
before it became the school of data
science and the co-director and sorry
and is the co-director of the
integrative translational Health
Institute of Virginia and recently he
was appointed as a board member to the
artificial intelligence industry
Innovation Coalition for healthc care
and he is one of 12 Executives on the
board representing Forward Thinking
organizations AI leadership and
Innovation and continuing with our 2023
2024 biomedical data science seminar
series theme Don's lecture today is
entitled label efficient learning for
biomedical and educational applications
Don will uh tell us about recent um deep
learning based methods achieving very
promising performance and a variety of
applications um which also include
biomedicine and education and yet the
training of deep learning methods
requires a large amount of annotated
data which is timeconsuming labor
intensive and Don will describe two
approaches to dealing with this problem
one developed for educational
applications which uses large language
models up to label teacher questions and
a second use um of a new label efficient
um contrastive learning based uh
approach to detect and classify various
types of nuclei in 3D imuno florescent
images and as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and if you're watching on
YouTube thank you very much for joining
us also our specially selected 2023 2024
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are really
encouraged to submit any questions they
have um for uh by uh via the YouTube uh
Channel I will synthesize any questions
and I will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Don we
really really are looking forward to
your presentation thank
you get on mute here yes thank you I
appreciate it Jack thanks for the
introduction
okay let's
see
there we
go I'm sorry this was the uh the QR code
that Jack mentioned there it
is um okay uh I guess that I'd like to
mention that uh this work uh that I'm
going to be talking about today is uh
it's takes a team uh Team science to
make this work uh I have a number of
graduate students these three are the
ones that particularly worked on many of
the items that I'm going to talk about
today jablonsky pton M MCB and nazanine
moradin um uh they've done really
fantastic work the first two Jim and
Peyton have graduated and are off to
other things and nazanine will be
graduating this next semester in the
spring semester so it's been really
great to work with them um the agenda
today I'm going to talk about is on in
the areas of machine learning computer
vision uh those two are the the sort of
foundational things that I'll mention
I'm not going to go into a lot of uh
mathematical detail on these things but
I will give you sort of the overview to
to how they're are foundational for what
it is that we're talking about when we
talk about these problems of label
efficiency and then I'll go into uh the
the techniques that people have been
adopting and some of the methods that
we've developed in order to improve uh
performance uh for these deep learning
methods and then end in with a brief
summary um okay so when we think about
uh um these problem s obviously we start
with machine learning which is
effectively taking data and and from
that data deriving patterns of various
types and and uh and and Concepts that
we can pull out of that data and uh a
lot of times we talk about the data as
extremely large and certainly there are
many many important problems that are
that are very large data problems but
there are also a lot of problems
particularly in the healthcare industry
that are small data problems and I'll
mention some of those today as we go
through our disc discussion um sort of
foundational method from the beginning
in machine learning is what's called
supervised learning the the most uh a
powerful of these techniques uh
initially developed for machine learning
which you take uh you know as the
diagram on the left here shows you've
got a a bunch of uh data points that are
labeled uh the stars and the circles and
and basically because of these labels we
can then develop some kind of um again
structure that's with the machine
learning process process does is develop
some structure mathematical uh function
that will allow us to basically
transform the data into classes so we're
going to take these stars in circle
labels and we're going to conform them
into a function and in this case we've
we've got a tree function which is a
very simple way to do it uh and in
future data points if we see something
that's less than x star or and less than
x double star we'll think it might be a
a red circle uh and we're we're wrong
sometimes but not very often is the
idea okay
um we've gone beyond these kind of uh um
tree likee structures in order to uh to
create machine
learning um functions and uh and we've
used what are called artificial neural
networks for the last uh 50 plus years
going in and out of favor and now
clearly the favorite approach um and
these artificial networks are designed
to uh in some way mimic the way that the
the human brain performs um they are
built on two other major uh
contributions though in addition to the
mathematical infrastructure of the
artificial neural network themselves
you've got uh the graphical programming
units uh which are really the the
backbone for a lot of what people have
done in in gaming in in uh in media and
in in movies U these units allow really
really realistic
representations um they're they're so
powerful in in the way that they display
uh colors on the screen uh that people
uh really are are just I mean I'll just
say I am personally Amazed by the
quality of the uh the graphics that we
have now as a result of of these gpus
but it turns out that the same basic
unit can be used for uh uh for machine
learning in particular deep learning for
these artificial neural networks and
that's they made it possible this is
very much like um um you know the the
Gold Rush uh in the 18 in the 1800s in
California when the uh the people who
really made the money were the ones who
were selling the uh the pickaxes and the
and the shovels not the ones who are out
there using them and in in some ways
right now the people are making the gpus
are making more money than the people
who are generating the AI uh because
they are providing the backbone for what
uh what is going on
in addition there's distributed
computing that's the other component the
other infrastructure backbone to uh to
this current machine learning boom uh
and it is in fact
um uh also key key to being able to
deploy these uh these systems
effectively okay so an artificial neural
network then is is basically a series of
of well it is as they say a mathematical
function but each of these components
represents uh these nodes represents a a
transfer function where the the uh the
arcs that are coming into them are
weighted layers as the data comes across
those arcs multiplied by those weights
it gets summed up in the uh the neuron
and then it uh a function uh operates on
that to decide whether what the output
from that neuron will be and this is all
put together um in multiple layers uh
and there and now there many many layers
not just the the the three hidden layers
that I show here but many many more
creating these deep networks and that's
what uh was it's behind most of what is
occurring currently in machine learning
and the breakthroughs that we're seeing
in natural language processing and
computer vision uh it's these are the
this is the uh infrastructure that's
powering it uh it's curious if you go
back and look at the history of this it
uh the name artificial neural network is
uh is kind of because that was one of
the motivating factors but actually in
the 50s uh there were a lot of ways that
people were taking on effectively the
same basic structure and using different
kinds of mathematical components and at
one point there was a there was a group
of folks who were that call these things
cybernetics and so we could have ended
up if that method had turned out to be
the more powerful than the method that
actually is employed in these uh
perceptron based uh systems we would
have probably we would have been calling
at cybernetics but as it was that that
particular version of things W out and
that particular set of names one out in
the in the as a result of that being the
way that it was Associated but I I will
say that there's nothing no one has ever
shown any mathematical foundational uh
um support for this it's just that these
work in practice and other versions
don't work in practice and that's how
we've ended up with what we have but uh
to date there's really no foundational
uh Concepts that that guarantee that
it's just empirical it's just that they
seem to work and they do work very very
effectively okay there are a number of
applications that people have used this
for U and there are three here now one
is computer vision which I will talk
about today the other one is natural
language processing which I was going to
talk about but as they put together
these slides I realize that uh I really
don't have a lot of time to talk about
it but this is the part that is the Ed
education based simulation that that
Jack mentioned in the introduction and
I'm happy to answer questions on that if
people want but I I'm a I'm afraid I
concluded that I really need a whole
another talk to to go into the details
of that that is based primarily on these
large language model kinds of topics but
much of what I'm going to talk about
today is directly applicable to that as
you'll see as we go through it the uh
the time series is another thing that
I'll end with that uh that is something
else that we we're using this happens to
be cardiopul Ary exercise test data but
there are a lot of Time series for which
these kinds of things have been employed
and um and the problems that we
mentioned that I'm mentioning today uh
uh apply to so if we think about
computer vision we can break it into a
number of areas the first one is
classification that's the simplest of
all areas and that uh we've got a
picture in this case we've got a bird
and we run it through one of these
neural networks and we get a um a
classification of that of that picture
now now this was a problem uh up until
about
2012 that was was not very well handled
by a lot of the uh the systems that
people had built and a lot of the
artificial intelligence systems that
they that had been built and there's the
famous imag net version of this where we
have a lot of these pictures and they
were not being classified very well and
then in 2012 we have Alex net we
suddenly start getting classifications
that are really good and then by 2016 we
get classifications of IM that are
exceeding Human Performance so we start
seeing this problem being solved pretty
well by these these neural nads there's
the localization problem this problem is
finding the object in the image so it's
not just hey this image is of a bird
this image is of the Eiffel Tower but
where is it in the image and then we can
extend that to object detection which is
we've got a bunch of objects we've got
people we've got cars uh we've got um
pedestrians or we've got bicyclists
we've got lots of things in this uh this
image and we want to basically uh uh
categorize all of those we want to
detect those objects and we want to
categorize them another version of this
is tracking where we're not only looking
at object detection but we're actually
looking at object detection over time
where the objects move and this is U
this is cinematography for instance uh
semantic segmentation this is where we
take an image and we break it into the
classes so there's you can consider
semantic m mation is pixel level
classification so we're looking with the
pixels within the image and we're
classifying what those are these objects
this part of the image consists of cars
this part of the image consists of
buildings and so forth and so we see
these um we we break down the image into
these uh to these subp
parts uh we can look at uh instant
segmentation is being another version of
that where we break it into the parts
but we actually now make another
classification within those uh that
segmentation so we've got a a
segmentation by people and then we we
break out oh this this is a particular
person uh so we've uh we've done a finer
level of
classification uh within the image um uh
in addition to the semantic
segmentation so there are a lot of
applications of this in healthcare and
these are some you know just quick looks
at the kinds of things that you can
think about when you when you think
about doing this um applying it to
healthcare uh you you've got image
classifications so for example you have
an image and you may want to classify it
as containing a tumor or not um you can
you can do object localization again
looking at where the cells are in the
image the specific cell types within the
image instant
segmentation uh so we break out sell you
know gulet cells within this area and
other cells in other areas in background
and that's what this is the semantic
segmentation then breaks out the cell
components from the background
components in order to understand what
what the presence is within that image
and we want to do things like counting
cells and see the presence of different
types of cells in an image in order to
better classified disease and and see
what the structure is for that image in
terms of its uh its uh usefulness toward
understanding what the disease
trajectory might be for the individual
patient so here's a histopathology
example of that we've got a a patch
typically these these uh these
histopathology problems take data from
uh tissue samples those tissue samples
are very very large so the data in these
things is is quite large now I'd say
that that's the good news the bad news
of course is is that there're only a few
of those samples so this is an example
of where it seems like you've got a lot
of data but you actually have very
little data because you may only have a
few of these whole slight images for uh
for particular kinds of diseases uh so
that's the that's the the issue that you
run up against when you when you look at
these problems because you've got a lot
of uh structure within the image itself
but you may only have a few of the
images then you have a classification
that you put on it this is usually done
by a human in order to create a labeling
structure over this uh this particular
image you you run that through your uh
your neural net and you get a prediction
in this case you're trying to predict
where you you know cils are in the image
and so you're looking at the structure
in order to do that kind of
prediction but we run up against the big
problem in this supervised learning it's
a it's a very powerful approach to uh to
doing machine learning but it requires
these labels and labeling is very time
consuming and expensive to do and if you
look at an image here of of a city you
can see all the different labels that
are required in order to uh to create uh
the structure that you need for that
supervised learning and if you look here
at another example from histopathology
you're trying to label those eosinophils
you've got to look very carefully at the
image to find these things and then
you've got to lab them you've got to
you've got to label them in some way you
either put the a center point on them or
you you draw uh um polygon around them
in order to to label where the these
particular things are and you've got
other things in here that are somewhat
confusing and may get uh may start
interacting so it may be that the case
that when the human is looking at this
they get distracted it's very difficult
for them to do the labeling and to do
them
correctly so labeling is the big problem
that uh that people have with uh with
supervised learning and it's it's such a
big problem that frankly I was at a
conference last week at Microsoft and uh
there actually were speakers there who
said that supervised learning is
effectively over that the age of
supervis learning has ended uh it
arguably ended uh several years ago but
it certainly we've moved away from it in
most problem spaces now we're now at the
level where we have to do other things
we can't do supervised learning in the
traditional way so one approach is to
use what are called weak annotations so
in this case we would we would not try
and annotate the whole cell we would
just annotate cell centroids and try and
leave it to the uh algorithm to discover
whether boundaries are for those cells
if we give it a a weak labeling or weak
annotation then uh the goal is to to
create an algorithm then that can take
that weak annotation and produce
something useful out of it
another approach that's been used really
since the uh early 2000s is domain
augmentation and uh this is a student's
dog but you take that uh that picture
and you can basically warp it in many
ways you can flip it around you can do a
lot of things to it in order to take one
um labeled image and make multiple
labeled images from it so you can say oh
this is still the same dog it's just
been we've just moved we've taken we've
cropped it we've done various things to
it in order to uh to create more labeled
images that we can use for a training um
that works for some things but it
actually doesn't work very well for a
lot of problems and uh you know it's
easy to come up with examples of where
it doesn't you know if you think about
digit labels it's a very straightforward
thing to see what happens that uh you C
you can only do this you know this uh
rotation so many ways before suddenly
the object becomes something quite
different it's no longer a nine it now
looks like a six or maybe even a
lowercase b uh so we have the problems
with this kind of thing but we have the
problem as well with with lots of other
domain areas like time series we can't
really do this kind of uh warping and
rotation and so forth with some data
sets so it makes it very difficult to uh
to to apply domain augmentation a
straightforward way to problems to a lot
of
problems so one of the approaches that
people have used is what's called
transfer learning which is to say okay
let's take uh some labels that we've got
from one area and apply it to another
area and uh an example of this for uh
for healthc care is to take um U you
know images from that image net data set
that I mentioned earlier uh that we've
got and it's well you know it's it's
well labeled for us and and train models
using that uh that image net um data set
and then apply that to Medical Imaging
so use that as a way to apply to the
medical imaging or we could uh we could
take data sets in medical imaging and
see and use that as a pre-training uh
approach well one of my students took a
look at this question as to whether or
not uh this transfer learning can be
used as just a a basic initialization
technique so in other words we learn the
initial weight structures in the neural
net does that improve the training of
the neural net if we start out with uh
uh with with images that are actually
histopathology images in order to do the
histopathology problem as opposed to
using image net or random
initialization and uh I looked at two
state-of-the-art architectures as those
two were unet and hnet uh I'm going to
say more about hnet a little bit here
but um
and then he looked across this problem
of segmentation with four channel four
different data
sets and it turns out curiously enough
that the results he got were that uh
actually image net weights are as good
or better than uh than using
histopathology as a starting point and
all but one experiment that he did uh
and that actually the computations were
compatible as well so it turns out that
you don't really need uh uh to to start
with a with a health data set a
histopathology data set for a lot of
these problems that getting the initial
weights from image net is just fine
which means that you can you can do your
problem without worrying about coming up
with a new label data set specifically
for your problem domain uh you can start
with a uh with a standard data set and
that turns out to work pretty well as a
base case for for starting the problem
there there was one case where it didn't
work and that case uh will I'll talk a
little bit about later but it's a it's a
fairly special
case well okay so let's take this
transfer learning idea and let's extend
it a little bit and think about the
problem area more generally so if we
think about transfer learning from the
standpoint of um moving to uh to across
expanding the domain of applicability
for our problem so we're going to train
on some set of data and then we're going
to try and apply it to a broader set of
data or even a different set of data
then the question is uh you know what
kind of techniques really work for that
and we can think about this as breaking
out in these in roughly the the
description that's shown here so we've
got a source domain and if that Source
domain is not labeled in the Target
domain the domain you're going for is
not label then that's what we call
Totally unsupervised learning and I'm
not really going to talk about that one
today because um we actually have a lot
of cases as I just said we can in fact
use things like imag net and other
things there are data sets that are
labeled the question really is can we
take those labeled data sets and use
them more effectively then we don't have
to uh or use them effectively in a in
another domain and so we don't really
have to start with a completely
unsupervised case is uh is I guess the
argument that we'll make um and and for
that same reason we don't really worry
about this really specialized area this
one where Source domain is is not
labeled and the target domain is labeled
um which is a selftaught learning which
again is uh that's a pretty special case
um the case where we've got us a domain
a source domain labeled and a Target
domain unlabeled is the case that I'll
think about in the rest of this talk and
this is the one that we really have
pretty much across a lot of of our
problem space or our application space
in healthc care and in other areas uh
which is unsupervised domain adaptation
is the name of the area um and again
this multitask uh learning is another
specialized area that we won't consider
here so domain adaptation you can s
think of it as very simple you've got
some training data you've got some test
data the test data are different they're
similar maybe to the to the training
data and so that's the question that
you're asking is is can you do that
adaptation another way to look at it is
uh is this way and we'll we'll make it a
slightly more formal in just a second
but you know you've got a you've got
domain one got domain two and and the
question is uh is there has there been a
domain shift uh in that kind of uh
structure um can you get a cross domain
uh classifier from these uh from these
multiple domains and and we can think
about this this idea of domain shift
this way uh we can think about whether
or not the uh the the feature uh data
set the the data set of features and the
uh the probability distribution over
that data set is consistent between the
source and the target domains if it's
not we've got a coari shift if the uh if
the feature uh space is changing then we
have a covarage shift if the label space
is changing so in other words the labels
are different uh within this U again
within the the feature structure that
we've got the feature space that we've
got then we have a label shift uh and
then we can have a different U
uh conditional probability shifts we can
have a concept shift where if you will
um the posterior the the probability of
our response given our data is different
between uh the two so the model this
would imply we need a a different model
so the concept is it's a it's a this is
a diff really difficult problem because
the model effectively is Shifting
between the domains and we can have a
conditional shift which is uh this is if
you well likelihood shift between the
source and the uh the target domain so
those those two represent the more
difficult ones these are the things that
we typically think about uh the ones
that are shown in this sort of pinkish
color here this one is represents really
a change in problem for us and so we we
we think about these three when we think
about domain shift
typically okay one approach to doing
this is what's called um uh unsupervised
main or I'm sorry one approach to
unsupervised domain adaptation is what's
called adversarial training and this
architecture includes what this Green
Layer which is a uh deep feature
extraction layer um and a prediction
layer which is in the blue which
together for you know these are really a
standard feed Ford uh classification
that we would think of in a in a typical
um problem supervised learning problem
the difference here is the red structure
which is an
unsupervised
um domain adaptation uh component uh and
this is uh this is comes out of the it's
connected to the feature layers in the
green uh in order to do a domain
labeling so in addition to doing a class
labeling we're doing a domain labeling
and the way that we we do this is we we
do this using a gradient reversal so we
have a gradient reversal layer in order
to improve the learning of this domain
uh classify classification
layer so the first version of things
then is that uh domain or that
adversarial training approach the second
approach to U um unsupervised domain
adaptation is what's called
self-training self-training is a
conceptually easier way to think about
it because you have basically you've got
your labels you've got your images uh
you've got your your um your deep
learning uh algorithm and what you do is
you apply that you put those two
together you get a you get a series of
predicted labels and from those
predicted labels then you extract some
pseudo labels what is a pseudo label a
pseudo label is a predicted label that
you now say oh it's so good that I think
it rank it ranks at the level of one of
the true labels that I had originally so
I'm going to put it together with my
original labels the pseudo labels and
the labels in order to to produce a a
better classifier for the new domain so
I'll be able to classifying that new
Dean better with those pseudo labels
treated as
labels obviously the challenge is is
that this thing U can't be easily
adjusted uh to different inputs or
network parameters and it really depends
upon uh how we do the pseudo labeling so
we're going to spend a few moments in
order to talk about how we do this this
pseudo labing because that's really a
key component of how we get the label
structure so one obvious approach to uh
to doing the pseudo labeling is to just
label based upon the U certainty you
have about that label so you're going to
say oh gosh um I'm going to create a
label which is uh very very likely um uh
I'm going to create a label when I think
that it's very very likely to be that
label okay um the problem with that
though is is that it sometimes biases
you I mean uh first of all it's still
difficult to know what that what that
threshold is but it's also the case that
it could bias you it could be the places
where you're getting high uh certainty
about classification only in a in a
section of the uh the source data that
really doesn't apply as well to the say
to the parts of the uh um uh Target data
uh that you really want the target
domain that you really want or it could
be that they're within the target domain
again but within only certain areas of
the target domain so that creates
problems for you so one of the things
that people have looked at is they've
looked at using um
um uh well the biggest approach here is
to use some kind of regularization and
the regularization that's used is is to
use an entropy minimization approach
which says that okay we're going to look
at this um
at the labeling for these uh these
objects in the in the image but we're
going to try and look at the labeling in
a way that uh that these are minimum
entropy labels so in other words there's
not as much there there it's not as
likely to be across other labels so
that's another approach that is that in
fact that is the standard approach that
people use right now in order to do this
these pseudo labeling
um so that's that's really the uh the
the state-of-the-art with regard to
trying to create pseudo labels is to
build these things based upon
that okay so one of the questions then
is um can we test this pseudo labeling
approach uh and again a student uh
Peyton took a look at this uh problem
and he looked at two ways to describe
the UNC he looked at the entropy of
those uh those labels but he also looked
at the standard deviation both of using
money car a Dropout uh and again the
idea is you you train the model uh you
uh with labels you get uh you apply to
your unlabeled data you get pseudo
labels and then you take the pseudo
labels and the labels and create a new
model with it and then you see how well
that new model works well in a in a
somewhat disappointing uh turn of events
it turns out that uh that you can't
always say that uh uh that this entropy
minimization is uh is going to give you
the protection you want in order to do
the pseudo labeling and in fact in
several cases we found that it worked
exactly the the opposite of of the way
that it we were hoping some cases we did
find that uh the decreased entropy led
to improve performance and dice score by
the oops sorry dice score by the way is
a performance Criterion for segmentation
so we're looking at again at this
segmentation and histopathology images
and it turns out that uh we do get some
examples of that but we also get
examples where that's not true and uh
and it really it turned out that the
reasons at least from what we could tell
in the testing that we did is because of
the size of the training Set uh and and
the training set and the training
performance both of which are very
disappointing because if the size it
arguably the size of the training set is
one of the reasons we're using the
pseudo labels to begin with um so if
that's a if that's a detractor then
that's going to make it very difficult
to uh to to find these uh these kind of
pseudo labels in this traditional way
and the other problem is is that if
training performance is is another
indicator then again that's a problem
because what we're interested in is
using pseudo labels to improve the
performance on uh on our new data so
both of those are somewhat disappointing
so it it suggests that we need more
advanced methods so one approach is to
use the contrastive learning um and
we're going to show how we've put
together some ideas of using contrastive
learning to get us a solution to these
kind of difficult problems uh
contrastive learning you can think of as
a as a kind of supervised learning
there's in fact supervised contrastive
learning and self-supervised
self-supervised is traditionally done
where we've got an anchor point this is
uh the the point that we're looking at
in order to compare other images too and
all in self-supervised the only things
that that are considered with uh uh
positive examples of the Anchor Point
are those domain augmented examples so
they're rotations and so forth and
slices of the original image um but in a
in a s in a supervised version of it we
would take things including cell pseudo
labels that are also part of it uh and
consider those as as positive examples
of the Anchor Point if they're
associated with it and this turns out to
be a useful approach um one approach
that was suggested by Shia and
colleagues is what's called sepo um and
that's a contrastive learning approach
where he takes these images and he's and
he's doing this this problem where he
looks at them basically looks at pixels
in in a in an embedding space so you're
looking not at the raw you know value of
a pixel but you're looking at this
Vector of components of the pixel for
each of the pixels then you do a cluster
cling uh and so you find um centroids
these these represent the anchor points
in this contrastive learning kind of
model so you find these uh these
centroids for these clusters you keep
those within a within a data set You
Keep A Memory of all of these uh these
centroids for for doing comparisons with
your um your target data set and you
again you look at your Target in the
same embedding space so you can do
comparisons and you look for for
distances to these targets uh based upon
um uh again doing the clustering and
then looking at distances to the Target
uh to the Anchor points choosing the one
that's closest uh and and going away
from the ones that are farther away so
you start to label then according to
that and that's that's an approach this
turns out to be a a reasonably powerful
approach there's also um there's also
distributions around once you get these
clusters and you can find the statistics
on them curiously they don't use them uh
within the uh for these distance
calculations which is something that
I'll hit upon here in a minute because
that's something we take advantage of in
the approach we use okay so just to
summarize then what we what we found so
far from this U uh unsupervised domain
adaptation um self-training approaches
have been shown to outperform
adversarial learning approaches so the
two approaches to um unsupervised domain
adaptation self-training does better uh
but we have the problems that we've got
generated pseudo labels they can be
noisy and
unreliable and using them as a result
can lead to error accumulation and using
only pseudo labels with high confidence
as I said can actually bias you in terms
of uh your your data set um a second
point is that the latent space comprises
distributions and this is the point I
made last time time or LA in the last uh
slide that we we get more than just
these uh clusters in in for instance in
the embedding space which I'm calling
the Enlighten space here but we actually
get statistics about those clusters and
we can actually think about those
distances then that we measure as being
statistical distances and not just ukian
distance the last thing is that
questionable assumption that we have
that the source domain uh data is
labeled completely inaccurately uh
almost everybody that's worked in this
area Works in this area makes that
assumption and and we find in the real
world applications that we work on that
that's not a good assumption to
make so we've built a system uh that's
based on this distribution based model
so let me let me just give you a
highlight from that what's going on
there do we look at the The Source
domain in green okay and the target
demand in yellow we get the statistics
uh for these clusters that we saw before
and now we we calculate distances to the
Target domain based upon a statistical
distance and we pick those that are
close and we actually choose even when
they're uh they're outside if they're
close statistically to other Target
domain points then that suggests there
may be a shift and we will adjust it so
these points will also get associated
with the same uh Anchor Point however
we'll we'll look at points that are
outside in the Target domain uh this
suggests again domain shifts and we will
we will cluster them separately we we
won't classify them if they don't meet
the Criterion to be within there the uh
the the anchor points for the uh Source
domain will treat them separately and
treat them as new classes in and of
themselves we did uh some evaluations of
this this is these data these
evaluations are classic domain uh
augmentation um
or domain adaptation uh problems um uh
the first is to use Grand Theft Auto now
I'll be honest I've been using this as a
as a uh as a source of data for about
eight years it's a it's a very powerful
way to get data in order to uh to do
segmentation and uh and object
recognition within uh uh uh images uh of
cities and and this is a citycape image
so you use Grand Theft Auto Now what is
Grand Theft Auto is a is a program it's
a game but all the components of it
because it's a game or labeled so this
is a labeled data set basically um and
this is an unlabeled data set and so you
can apply the labeling that you get out
of this data set AR obviously an
artificial data set a real data set but
you can apply it and see how well it
does this is a similar thing Cynthia is
a is a synthetic data set uh that was
created in order to do the same kind of
thing it comes with labels and then it's
applied to the cityscape model well I
guess the bottom line here is is it
across all the different areas of the of
the of the segmentation problem in
cityscape we do better with the the
approach that we take um and that's
that's encouraging so doing the the
kinds of statistical modeling that we
described in contrastive learning turns
out to give you a lift okay so let's now
turn to the question of how do we apply
this to a real problem a real Health
Care problem and the problem that we're
going to look at is the problem of U um
arterial sclerosis um it's a clearly a
major problem a major uh well heart
disease obviously a major killer in the
US and and a number of other countries
in the world um and it's it's a result
of U uh uh fatty material called plaques
that build up inside the artery and uh
and and it reduces the flow it can also
eventually or it can also sometimes
rupture as a result of unstable
conditions in the plaque and uh and
these ruptures can lead to heart attack
and strokes uh so this is a kind of
problem that we we're definitely
interested in solving and and working on
um and we take images and here's a
zstack image I'm going to show you in a
minute how we get those zstack images in
order to do it and we we've got these
from a lot of different uh data sources
these are describing some of the sources
that we yet we're Prim we're going to
look today primarily at lineage tracing
as a way to uh to understand the
problem okay so um here's a this is
what's called a zstack whoops a zstack
this is an imun fluorescent image of the
cell of the um of the tissue um and it's
uh it's taken across a number of uh
points these are number of slices if you
will in the uh in the fluoresence and
that creates a zstack I've got five of
the Z Stacks here in this example and
this one is showing the the cell nuclei
and this one is showing the lineage
tracing so you you've got these things
together and the question is when do
they uh uh when did they co-occur that's
one of the questions that you that you
ask when are the co-occurrence and do
they occur cooccur in the same zstack or
not so um the way that people typically
look at this problem is what's called
maximum intensity projection they look
at the uh the intensity in the different
uh components of the zstack in the
different slices they uh sum those up
they create a a projection in in each of
those uh in both the nuclei and in the
lineage tracing and then they do a
linear combination to get that uh
um uh that uh
display uh that z um display of them
that shows the combination now there's
some issues with this
um first one is there noisy annotations
because typically what happens is that
the human being annotates only one of
the elements of the zstack okay so they
only annotate one of these and uh if
they only annotate one then it could be
the case that uh that there are problems
with that so for example if they were
annotate um just uh you know this cell
that cell disappears in in other parts
of the Z stag so it's only present in
one place and yet it appears uh you know
annotated that way so in other words if
they look at it this would be an example
here where they look at it and they see
that the cell and the uh and the marker
the lineage traced marker occur together
but uh they don't occur together here so
it depend upon where they looked as to
whether or not they found that uh that
co-occurrence the other problem with
that uh that projection is shown in this
one because uh you could see that the
the cell and the the the marker never
cooccur in the same z uh trace or in the
same slice Z slice but they but if you
were to do the projection it would
appear as if they were occurring
together and that would be incorrect so
you have those kind of problems uh you
know that's the the overlap problem and
um and so these are the kinds of things
that create problems for doing this that
create problems for uh for doing this
domain um adaptation so we've created an
approach which we
call label efficient contrastive
learning or lecl and it's got these two
parts it's got extended maximum
intensity projection and and contrastive
learning Based training let me just
quickly give you those because uh we're
not going to have too much time but the
the uh the extended maximum intensity
projection the algorithm is here it
basically uses a combination of things
it generates these 3D distance Maps
again using uh the same kind of distance
that we talked about before using
statistical distances we create um
clusters based upon this we create a
borid label based upon this and then as
a result of that we can get maps we can
get maps for
uh how the uh the cell and the and the
marker behave within the Z traces and
use that in order to do the projection
and this turns out to work very well
when we look at uh uh here's an example
of uh we've got four different points
here where in fact um we found we show
that there is no overlap with the marker
and yet if you just use maximum
intensity projection in all four of the
cases it thinks there is the marker and
the cell occur at the same point but
when we look at what the humans said in
their ground truth annotation we see
that they agree or that we are
consistent with what the human uh Point
annotator found when they looked at it
so in fact we we find that this approach
does much better for that kind of
result we combine that then with this
contrastive learning uh the contrastive
learning has three parts to it
um the it's got a hover Branch obviously
the hover branch is is there uh because
we found that that works extremely well
when it comes to uh um doing uh
detection and
classification the the NP or the N the
nucleus pixel Branch this branch is
trained using the cluster labels that we
described before and we use a cross
entropy loss in order to toh to get
these Mass okay and then uh the final
one is our nucleus classification Branch
uh which we um incorporate pixel to
pixel and pixel to region supervised
contrastive learning in order to do our
segmentation we get as a result we get
these one part of is we get these
cluster labels and the cluster labels
show the areas we show this the extent
of the nucleus and we also show the area
where we're uner which is the black and
then we show background so we get that
kind of result directly out of this uh
this work um when we evaluate it again
we find that we can do extremely well
for example again we can see cases where
the cell and the and the marker occur
together in one one slice but not in
other slices and we correctly detect
that and then we see cases where it
doesn't occur where we correctly detect
it so this is showing where they go
together and this is showing where they
don't go together in the output and when
we look at performance we see that
pretty much overall across two different
data sets that we ranted on now just to
show you this data set has 12 um images
12 of those Z stacked images in it and
this one has 20 so we're talking about
relatively small data sets which is why
we need to do this in order to get these
kind of uh U Learning approaches to work
well and our approach does better than
uh than the other approaches across but
across F1 score and across recall and
all but one case across Precision so
we're seeing it doing very very well in
terms of its performance for these kind
of
problems I guess I want to end by
telling you that U this approach can be
used for lots of other things we're
looking at time series versions of it so
we're extending it to time series uh I I
met uh earlier this week with somebody
who's an opthalmologist who has almost
exactly the same issue in terms of
looking at their images of the eye that
we just described with these uh uh
zstack images that we that we talked
about so these kinds of problems occur
again and again and we're also applying
it as I said at the beginning to
problems with the
um uh large language
models okay so summary um label
efficient learning critical to
successful applications of machine
learning um simple self-training will
fail on some important problems so uh
it's better to use the kinds of things
that we talked about here distribution
based clustering approaches contrastive
learning approaches they show the
promise for label efficient learning in
a variety of different domains and our
next steps are do we we're building out
diffusion models and applying it in the
general class of generative AI so I'll
stop there and take your questions Don
thank you so much that was really really
great and I was intrigued when you
started that that you'd mentioned that
you'd been to a meeting with Microsoft
and that one of the themes was that
supervised learning is dead and it's
been dead and you like in the grave for
a couple of years and maybe we're just
waking up to that um and that
self-training was something that you
also mentioned and could you talk a
little bit more about self-training and
you know what do what are your what are
you hearing from folks in Industry about
uh applications of that where they have
just much big data sets than we'll maybe
ever have yeah well I mean again I think
that
uh what I described is obviously
everything from uh you know that I've
described in the techniques we're using
are all self-training techniques so
these are all within that class which is
effectively taking and building these
pseudo labels out of uh out of what
you've got in your data sets in very
very clever ways that's what it amounts
to is it's all about being very clever
about how you you create those labels
it's not not just as easy as I pointed
out as as looking at the most likely
ones the ones that are boy I'm sure this
is uh you know a frog or whatever uh you
want to or this is a gobblet cell you
want to basically look at other
characteristics in order to to make
those labels um so I guess that I'd say
this yeah everybody is is using some
version of self uh self-training uh it's
just a question as to what their
application area is whether it's this
Vision area which we've been talking
about here today or whether it's things
like natural language processing or time
series data more generally that they're
looking at but they're looking at ways
to do this this kind of self-training um
in order to get the the structures that
they need for the algorithms to learn
how do you deal with things like you
know bias in the data and the generation
of the pseudo labels yeah that's that's
as I said I think that's a critical
component of it um and I I will tell you
this I think that uh um we've explored
it to some extent and we found that
we're doing really well on the problems
that we've got on the other hand I don't
we don't have any any general purpose
recommendations for how to control for
that and I think that's an area that's
right for a PhD student to go after I
think it's particularly important for us
to think about this problem because as I
said one of the issues is is that uh uh
you you can become biased if you choose
um your labels based upon your pseudo
labels based upon criteria that tend to
bias your algorithm in certain
directions and how to find those biases
uh it's much much harder than it is to
find biases in your traditional
supervised learning because then you can
say oh look you just don't have enough
labels of this of X but in this case uh
it's much harder because your pseudo
labeling algorithm is the one that's uh
creating the bias and it's harder to
detect it there yeah I was going to ask
is you know when there's a human in the
loop I suppose that's creating the
labels a priori then the bias I suppose
that the responsibility for the bias
lies with the human in the loop whereas
in the pseudo labels the bias you know
maybe in the data already and the
computer is just kind of not seeing
something that would be ordinarily
present to anybody else and it would be
difficult to faret that out possibly
that's right yep that's exactly right
yeah these are I think the good news for
for phds is there's still despite the
appearance there's still very important
problems to be tackled here uh and work
to be done absolutely and that was going
to kind of get to my next question is
you know what sort of ways do you feel
that the people who are developing
methodologies like this not only in
industry but in Academia how can they
work closely with people doing work in
education to train I don't know just you
know educate people on the uses of these
correct or incorrect uses their pitfalls
and and potential you know
benefits yeah I I think that's an
important point I think we need to we
need to basically I think the more we go
into the area of um you know this uh
domain adaptation the more we need uh to
educate people on the use of the
algorithms and how they they will be um
you know how they work in some ways but
there there's the potential for these
problems that we've talked about and I
think that uh it's uh it's become even
more critical I'd say that it's uh it's
critical at the level that uh for
managers who won't get down in the level
that we've been talking about here of
building Al algorithms to do this but be
making them aware of the fact that the
algorithms that their companies or their
organizations are using have that
potential is important uh those
potential issues is important for them
and in the deploying of them in the
deploying of the AI
Solutions I think you know things in
this space are happening so fast and
there's this like arms race to come out
with the next big thing and you know it
was only earlier this year that chat GPT
sort of became you know part of people's
Consciousness and then I was going to
ask you about you know just it wasn't
that long ago what a couple of weeks ago
that Google Gemini came out which you
know very impressive uh looking stuff
where there it's not just text it's
images it's possible sound it's you know
multiple modalities in which case these
things are you know they're cutting
across multiple domains do you see that
as an area of you know places where
pseudo labeling can can happen or maybe
it already is happening at across
multiple no it is absolutely happening I
mean I think that the the evant you have
in the large language models is is that
the way that they solve the labeling
problems is that they were they're now
predicting the next word kind of thing
or the next uh you
know at least the next word and that's a
so you've got you basically have your
labels in your data and you can you can
create uh structures based on that same
thing with a lot of the image uh you
know uh computer vision stuff that
people have done like Google right now I
mean it you it's easy to say you know in
retrospect gosh you solved an easy
problem you only solve natural
language but it's I don't get me wrong I
think the What's happen in
gp4 uh you know and others uh is just
amazing and but it's because first of
all they've they've their version of of
how they're doing the labeling is is
more straightforward than it is in a lot
of the problems that you and I work in
frankly in health where it's not it's
not you can't do you don't have an
equivalent to a next word problem um or
you know um uh an image problem that is
uh that has got you know it's it's
reduced in terms of its complexity uh
these are complex images that uh frankly
it's very very difficult to know and you
know I mean I I point out that like
Pathologists they're looking at images
that frankly humans have you know we we
didn't look at until relatively recently
it wasn't look like like our ancestors
on the Savannah ever saw tissue images
um this kind of thing was just you know
it's unheard of and yet they're trying
to find structures in that so what they
were doing for years on their own
without uh help from uh computer vision
was extremely difficult now they're
getting help from it but the news is is
that uh we've got a lot of cases where
you know we got some labels in there and
actually we don't really even know if
those labels are correct because um you
know we we're not sure that they got it
right when they created the label
structure that they did so I guess
that's all by saying that I as I say I
think the problems that we're working on
remain extremely difficult because the
labeling issues for us are more
challenging in many ways than the
problems that uh that have been tackled
not that those problems aren't hard in
not that the results aren't impressive
they're just different there's certainly
a lot of work to be done in this space
and and bringing multiple domains
together to help kind of teach each
other about the elements which are
important so that labeling can be made
properly and that these models can be
more accurate and reliable is always the
I guess is the the Holy Grail of this
whole thing and in being able to train
people about their effective use is a is
a very responsible goal um Don Brown
from the School of data science at the
University of Virginia thank you so much
for giving us this synopsis and this
summary of your work and and where the
field kind of is and where it might be
going we really appreciate that and uh
everyone this will be our last
biomedical data science seminar series
for uh
2023 uh we will look forward to seeing
everybody on January 5th uh and where
we'll uh Begin Again in 2024 everyone
have a wonderful holiday um with your
family and your friends
and we will talk to you again next year
thank you again Don thank you byebye bye
everyone